how you doing there bud i'm fine i'm
great well i hear your mouth say that
but the rest of your head is telling a
different story
feels like the stress of the upcoming
trial is starting to get to you oh is
this about my hair turning white
yes definitely it's not just the head
hair
it's all of it all of
it i get it it's like an eagles concert
down there nothing but whites
understood you got white pubes there's
no need to stress out the lawyer is very
confident not good enough
i need to do everything i can to save
jake charles you're falling apart
and that's not helping anyone you need
to get your crap in order
okay yeah you're right
i'll take a nap i'll eat
i'll dye my pubes you can dye all your
hair no there's no time
i'm gonna go check in on sharon make
sure she's not pushing prematurely
fatiguing the uterus okay
wait you can't talk to her
terry doesn't want you in there you make
her uncomfortable
i make her uncomfortable oh that's
ridiculous
i should go confront her about this at
length no wait you could
but i think that would probably stress
her out and we're trying to keep her
calm right now so maybe just focus on
work
of course i only want to help whatever's
best for sharing
really you're fine with that absolutely
i don't take it personally i mean it's
about me
and my behavior specifically nobody else
not hitchcock or scully but
yeah i'm fine what a joyous occasion
he's looking at us pretend to use the
ice machine boyle gladly
why is it so funny at hotel ice it feels
wasteful but also like
i bought this room i deserve this house
he's on the move
okay i'll follow to the acpd yeah
damn it stay put for awesome i will
don't worry i'm just gonna let sarge
follow him i'm gonna stay right here i
can't do it i'm gonna cut him off in the
alley
ah shortcut you just got james
oh oh jake oh
hey you okay no serge
i got hit by a car oh
you happy now broken ribs and a million
broken toes weren't enough for you
in retrospect they were plenty yes the
worst part is olson got away
that's the worst part you could have
died man
i wasn't hurt that badly the doctor said
all my bleeding was internal
that's where the blood's supposed to be
the only way out of this hole is to keep
digging that's not how holes work
title your sex tape charles look you're
gonna find your way out of this i swear
it's all gonna work out you're right you
know if i just work hard and stay
positive
i'm sure it'll be a huge success and
everything will be okay here you go
hello oh okay
no thank you so my truck burned down
that was your first dent in solitaire it
was nothing i held it together
oh amy when'd you get here
you've come for my conjugal capabilities
you're looking real good girl
oop lost a booby and no matter i'll just
build another one
more mashed potatoes
all right everyone calm down just calm
down
let us out well i'm gonna stop breaking
things this is a human rights violation
you can't keep us here i'm
23. i'm a celebrity and today i'm gonna
die
not one word of that is true
who hitchcock's bleeding he got hit in
the head with a soda can he never saw it
coming
jake we have to start putting people in
detention we have to quash this
no we need them to calm down we need to
put on something's got to give
great idea great movie also we should
probably put out that fire
so captain i have some news
what happened well remember when you
told me not to burn down the precinct
you burned down the precinct no i had
the fire put out almost
immediately this is a success story tell
me exactly what happened
well it started with boyle wanting to
say the word succulent
oh no and it ended with a small riot in
which a dirtbag set hitchcock's snap
couch on fire
okay so those guys look down on you so
what
i mean amy's parents look down on me
they talk about me right in front of my
face in spanish because they don't think
i'm smart enough to learn another
language but i've been taking classes
and now i can understand all the hurtful
things they've been saying
and how did that help well now i know
they think i'm short and i was able to
do some research and find that 1940
census that proves i'm above average in
height
for 1940. yeah i'm taller than the
greatest generation it doesn't matter
jake this was a mistake we have to get
landon on the stand now what why and how
would you describe the lieutenant he
works for hawkins he put the money in
the accounts
melanie hawkins was the most honorable
cop i ever worked with
and the only reason i am here is because
of that man
jake peralta he offered me three hundred
thousand dollars to lie
and say that she set him up
okay okay this is bad this is really bad
but just remember
we are not going to jail we didn't do it
we're innocent
guilty on all charges
oh guilty very cool
cool cool i want you to follow her and
make sure she doesn't betray us
and uh don't tell peralta count me in i
got nothing else going on
aren't you supposed to be getting ready
to transfer to staten island ah that's
not real it's pretty real last week
that's before i decided to pretend it
wasn't
i'm in denial most people who were in
denial don't usually say they're in
denial that's because they're in denial
about being in denial
but i'm not in denial i'm in denial
is jefford's brain okay for this mission
yes sir for this and all future
nine-nine missions which i'll definitely
be a part of let's go
a member of the commissioner selection
committee is coming in today to tour the
precinct and do some interviews would
you mind speaking with her of course
terry loves answering the hard questions
oh here she is
i guess you don't have time to take off
those ridiculous suspenders what hello
ms sumter hello captain i'm excited to
speak to your subordinates and learn
more about your management style
i thought you could talk to sergeant
jeffords here sergeant oh
um i'd rather not talk to a supervisor i
was hoping to interview one of your
detectives
perhaps um him no
excuse me there was a wasp near me which
has
since disappeared you can interview
detective hitchcock and i am completely
fine with that all right bye christmas
is gonna be amazing
christmas is gonna suck i don't have the
present what but you promised nikolaj
i ordered it a month ago from a latvian
toy story and it still hasn't arrived
yet
the shipping company is giving me the
run around all right so just get him a
different present like a
jet ski or a hammer i don't know what
kids are into genevieve and i worked so
hard to get nikolaj to trust us when we
brought him home
oh that's gonna be destroyed the way dry
rot destroyed his orphanage
trust me it's gonna be fine really cause
you said that about die hard five
jake oh
it's not gonna be fine
another cold brew don't mind if i cold
do nailed it i am loving this machine
that charles brought in it is nice the
trick is to let the coffee warm up the
room temperature i'm already on my
second cup this is my third
stop you're drinking too much
whoa what's going on charles why are you
talking so slow i'm not
i'm normally
oh my god if you're not going so that
means we're going faster are we going
fast can i tell if we're going fast
we're going fast at all in any way
whatsoever i feel like we're going slow
and everywhere whatsoever kept not even
great excellent amazing i feel better
than i've ever found any moment in my
entire life so we're all fine yep
you